welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse Liz filet mignon welcome back to
new rock stars I'm Erik Bosse this is
Philip Malina and this is a big question
it's our Q&A show where we dance with
the devil in the details of all the
nerdiest table talk one can muster what
Eric just said of the exact kind of
nerdy crap that's going to be prevalent
this entire episode
there is one Star Wars question many
have asked us over the years and Philips
gonna tackle it for us this episode why
didn't our theater force choke Luke any
of the times they battled yeah it kind
of seems like a plot hole and I'm always
like hesitant to jump into plot hole
once this just like just enjoy the movie
yes but this one I actually did get into
it and there is a pretty good reason
so you assigned this to me can I ask
real quick why did you assign it to me
um I don't know I feel like there's um
there's sometimes conflict between us
and there's times where you look at me
like you want a 4-stroke and I could
have why didn't I and I want to know
what's going on behind those eyes and
the decision not to show my eyes I just
thought what cover my eyes almost a
recurring pothole a lot of times when
you've established this ability to
4-stroke from not only across a room but
literally like on another ship through a
FaceTime conversation huh for shows
that's probably a good thing to use
against your enemies just regularly
constantly just like while you're
sleeping looking into this there
actually are pretty decent reasons why
he at least wouldn't have used it in any
of the Vader Luke fight scenes who are
watching my DeLorean right now you can
see any time that baby Yoda we've course
no he's not V biota but baby oda baba
yaga any time he goes to use the force
he does that very classic kind of three
fingers on how intense focusing
telekinesis through the force requires a
tremendous amount of meditation and
focus you can also see a one Lucas
training on Dagobah now could you
imagine doing that in the same way the
Bader is doing it with someone's throat
and also being in the middle of a fight
okay right being able to focus
tremendously on the telekinesis and
still be blocking attacks from a
lightsaber is probably
an effective defense of course too much
multitasking exactly yeah that's the
main reason why tactically it would be a
mistake to try to use a four-stroke
while you're actually battling someone
but that doesn't account for maybe when
Vader's in his own ship and he's trying
to stop Luke for making the the lethal
blow to the Death Star sure yeah
Vader could just be like well I got it
and then chokes him out and then you
know which would be easier for him to do
just in general to everyone yeah but I
guess he can't fly it'd be like you know
doing for sure yeah how much of this
force abilities is he using as he's
flying is he really actually a terrible
pilot or something he's doing a
crossword as the forces piloting the
ship he is the best pilot in the galaxy
supposedly is he or is his
midi-chlorians are any of our skills the
result of our soul or the result of our
genes a beautiful question there is a
separate reason why he doesn't use force
chokes on Luke when they're not in the
middle of a battle and this mostly you
can see in the comics it's really
prevalent whenever Jedi are learning
their various skills or magic tricks one
of the very first ones that they go
through is the ability to project
essentially a force shield over yourself
yeah like a Rick and Morty booby suit
basically and if you remember Yoda is
logic for Jedi powers the Jedi actually
are not supposed to use a force choke by
the way that's actually banned and
supposed to be only oh I use it and Yoda
is very clear about the Jedi powers
should only be used for defense blame I
know yeah so you can assume that Luke
kind of has this somewhat impenetrable
shield though I liked everybody go
through it but it also would explain a
little bit of in just in comics in
general a lot of characters let's say
maybe spider-man let's say Scarlet Witch
Scarlet Witch is an example of a
character who probably like secretly
always just has a little bit extra
endurance than the average human okay
just to explain why she could probably
take a blow from like Thanos or
something and just still sir why she's
not like nervously running on the
airport tarmac yeah exactly where these
people are made of metal made of normal
Jedi probably have some version of that
in general dislike super resistance to
outside attacks because there
in there little Jedi bubble just like I
was here no way yes what is also going
on this is my favorite part actually to
answer because I realized that there's a
deeper question here these two are
equally matched and that is actually
something that you are taught at a
certain point you are two equally match
for someone and that's the only time a
Jedi supposed to take out his lightsaber
mm-hmm so even though you know we've
seen Jedi use their lightsabers kind of
just to be mean at a bar right this is
an example of in actual battle with
someone else you should actually be
reserving your lightsaber for it's a
last resort if you need to use it and a
great example of this is when Yoda and
Count Dooku right yeah I mean because
they're roughly evenly matched at least
at this point that makes it so that now
they have to use their lightsaber yeah
it's like a sculptor using a
sledgehammer to just plow away at the at
the monoliths at first and then at the
very end stages you use a scalpel to
make the finding adjustments big big
smash smash and then tiny little like
all right now all you surgeons as big
big smash smash the hook that's my
surgery okay he just sunder claps
everybody until I feel better from a
different episode remember remember they
learned about that all right that leads
to then my favorite part of this whole
question that you're really asking who's
stronger Luke or Vader that's the real
big question but you picked it so that's
what I was emptying it the whole time so
a lot of people when you ask them who's
stronger they actually just jump right
at Vader
they're like I mean anakin skywalker
known as vijay i who blows everyone else
out of the water but actually if you ask
george lucas he would say to him as
cannon which he gets a kind of event
cannon not anymore but he used to was if
you were to take a midi-chlorian count
of luke skywalker it would match
Anakin's so that they actually have the
same little [ __ ] the inside of their
blood that makes them powerful jedi can
we know that qui-gon jinn had said that
Anakin had essentially off-the-charts
levels so does Luke so that's a good
indicator that they're predisposed to
being almost exactly
big matches but then on top of that you
have to think about the duration of that
fight and these multiple fights that
Luke survived Anakin Skywalker has been
trained by the best of the best is the
best of the best and Luke learned Jedi
yesterday yeah he had like I don't know
a couple weeks on Dagobah and a really
drunk old man is well this is the one
teaching him he actually survives the
battle and that's how you have to see it
against someone who should have been
able to defeat him immediately Luke
being as weak as he is in his journey he
eventually gets to this amazing place
that we see in last Jedi and holding his
own against Vader is the best evidence
that without without any training then
these guys are at least at this moment
perfectly balanced with each other and
on level which means they can't actually
use basic force tactics against each
other I like that I like that solution
because it makes sense that Dooku and
Yoda were kind of evenly matched because
Duke who used to be Yoda's apprentice he
learned from the master literally after
using all these other things that didn't
work it was just like unstoppable force
immovable object canceled each other out
now the lightsaber is really the only
way that you could edge each other out
because it's kind of like a sudden death
you know like at that point there can
only be one victor right and a good
example of this kind of the exception
proving the rule is there is someone who
is able to use the force against
characters like Luke invader and it just
clearly wins and that's the Emperor
sure the Emperor is able to use the
Force in the in those final moments and
we'd never see him needing to wield a
lightsaber because he's able to get it
done with the force alone so to finally
answer the question the big question of
the week is it a mistake that Vader
isn't using four strokes on Luke no
specifically not on Luke
is it a little curious why he doesn't
just walk around all day long closing
the windpipe of his enemies maybe he
actually could do it but actually you
probably enjoy is just swinging the old
saber around multitasking is hard I mean
this is why you don't do Sudokus while
you're driving support for big question
comes from manscaped who is the best in
men's below the belt grooming manscaped
offers precision engineer tools for your
family jewels
it's 20:28 know what that means new year
new me new balls men listen up Harry
bushes are so 2019 if you're going
pick up any new year's resolution this
year let it be to take care of your junk
manscaped is making it easy with their
grooming products you don't want to snag
your bag while trimming because force
healing may be a thing in the Star Wars
universe now but it's not a thing in our
universe
that's why manscaped has redesigned the
electric trimmer their lawnmower 2.0 as
proprietary skin safe technology so this
trimmer won't Knick or snag your nuts
manscaping accidents are finally a thing
of the past manscaping accidents are
finally a thing of the past and don't
use the same trimmer on your face as
you're using on your balls that's just
dirty manscaped also has the crop
preserver an anti chafing ball deodorant
moisturizer you already put deodorant on
your armpits why are you not putting
deodorant on the smelliest part of your
body get 20% off and free shipping with
the code big cue add manscaped com
that's 20% off with Free Shipping at
manscaped calm and use code big cue
start the new year off the right way by
using the best tools for the job
your balls will thank you and we're back
guys there are some major bite-sized
questions that I'm really excited about
gonna answer to that Eric is gonna
tackle this how this one's from at
spilly spits great name in the walking
dead Gerry's axe cuts a dude in half but
then is also unable to just cut a lock
on a chain so the question is is this a
mistake should an accident cut a person
clean in half
be able to just cut through a lock great
question we're constantly wondering this
when we're watching The Walking Dead
it's a right it yeah we did we
demonstrated r.i.p
dave the thing with the Walking Dead is
it's all about like the whatever
delivers the most gross out gore because
that's why we're watching the show at
this point now the question is referring
to in season 8 episode 4 the Savior
Gunther has kidnapped Ezekiel and Jerry
his henchmen who has his big battle axe
saves Ezekiel right when he's about to
die by cutting the dude in half
vertically through like his collarbone
through his chest basically we see a
shot of his back and like flesh splits
open and we just see is equal be like
huh and we don't know how clean like
Jerry takes another a whack at it
we don't really hear a clear sound to
tell us oh what
body-part was slashed open there but
it's implied that in one clean swipe
he's able to split this guy in half like
a pumpkin you're able to tell based on
the sound what body part has been played
you can't I bet like fully artists if
you were to play like a specific sound
effect be like that's an exactly brokest
but yeah but what's crazy about is this
same axe they're trying to get away from
some walkers and he can't hack open a
chain that's keeping the gate closed now
the thing about this is is researching
this a metal steel chain is actually
very very hard to cut with an axe
there was a youtuber his name is
Wrangler star and does this kind of
stuff like in a metal shop all the time
to see like it's kind of like a will it
blend
type thing or ballistics will attacks
left talked about that he was trying to
test to see if the scene in Cool Hand
Luke where Shane is cut he tried to do
it and what's not able to do it because
every time he tried to chop it is just
the blunt-force blow of the axe swing
would just push that metal link into the
wood of the surface that it was resting
on so it wouldn't cut it
it requires a tremendous amount of
strength on both sides Newtonian third
law there so what he was able to do is
get a still surface so we need a strong
steel surface pushing back against the
axe blow to wedge all that force on the
link itself and only then he was able to
cut it almost all the way through but it
was very hard and he had to get a full
swing so Jerry doesn't have any such
force pushing back against that chain so
yeah it would be really hard for him to
split a steel link chain open which has
a much much higher tensile strength than
human flesh and bone what is kind of
crazy about this moment is the fact that
Jerry could cut open a human with one
blow of an ax yeah it would it would
wedge probably in Gunther's chest and
then it would take him down
split him open like where's the entry
point it's they don't show the entry
point but yeah it's not like completely
straight down the head because the skull
is actually very hard I think I saw a
Mythbusters episode on that the skull is
not easy to break or just split open
like that you can fracture it for sure
and the femur are that are two of the
strongest bones to the body but going
through the collar bone the collar bone
is very easy to break today yeah it's
kind of like a seat belt and a tea
agree angle I would say yeah seatbelt
cut is is safe and it kind of goes
through we don't know if it goes through
like this crotch or his legs but it's
implied that it at least goes through
his chest and then it splits open like a
pinata
now we don't know how much calcium
Gunter's getting but it's safe to assume
that that part was ridiculous has just
done for shock value but it is plausible
that Gerry should not have been able to
cut open that link so that part of it is
safe to say great all right bitesize
question answered by Tyson's gross um we
talked about this uh here's next one at
Jana Lama Jana Lama Jana Lama
what was the nose cooking on the farm
planet and endgame no yeah endgame he's
got something he's got a whole sequence
where it's just like a cooking show well
we don't have an answer for this but we
can kind of look at some clues it looks
like some kind of stew it's in a kettle
over a fire he picks these plants from
his farm they look like some kind of
either a fruit or vegetable similar to a
tomato or an ear of corn or a squash
that you could just kind of like pick
off it's not a root vegetable like a
potato it probably would be a fruit
unless it's like a tomato cuz fruits are
usually sweet you want something more
savory if you're gonna make a stew
squash sounds like a good option my
guess is he's making like a butternut
squash style stew or a bisque he does
seasoned it which implies that he has
taste buds what's interesting is if you
look at the comics Thanos does not
require food that's comics Thanos he
uses the energy of like Infinity stones
to sustain himself so but also remember
the condition that he's in he's
basically got like the flu
yeah he's weak there and so he's like
I'm gonna make my you know old chicken
noodle he's limping and he doesn't have
the stones anymore he reduced them to
atoms also like anybody who does fitness
knows you can't get that jacks without
having like a heavy calorie intake every
day
it's comics every villain has just got a
huge physique but like he needs some
kind of gravity to work against his
muscles for them to grow that large but
he does have taste buds if he seasons it
like he wouldn't season food unless he
cared about how it changed it that's the
question we care about Stannis have
taste buds yeah I think it is something
interesting that like he seasons it it
it reminds us and evokes when the vision
spices the pepper cache like is he
trying to evoke what vision did because
vision can't taste either he doesn't
understand a concept of taste so maybe
there's like a bit of a vision
soul that speaking through vision in
that moment you guys do you guys want to
break down of all the superhero tongues
in the MCU in the meantime at Julia Wow
shower how common is Arthur flex
pathological laughter disorder if it's
real it is real it's based on a real
condition it's not named in the movie
but the closest analog we have in in our
medical science is called pseudobulbar
affect or PDA and it's actually it's
something that's common among stroke
victims
so it's characterized by frequent and
voluntary bouts of crying laughter or
other emotional displays exaggerated or
disconnected from the individuals actual
emotional state so this is something
that is actually fairly common it's
caused by brain injuries neurological
disorders that impact that part of the
brain that controls how we process
emotion and according to the Mayo Clinic
it affects 1 million people in the
United States a million a million living
right now up to a million because a lot
people suffer brain injuries a lot of
people get in car accidents or they're
older and they have strokes they don't
process emotion the same way it's not
like Arthur Fleck walking around in some
cases it is but most of the time it's
people who are suffering from a lot of
other conditions as well and that's kind
of like the least of your worries the
fact that they're laughing when they
shouldn't be laughing or crying when
they should be crying just to give you a
sense of the scale 1 million people is
roughly the size of the population of a
lot of cities ok California has a
million people it's half of Miami yeah
half of our subscribers have
inappropriate emotional responses to
things I mean that's all of them yeah as
do we
that's super interesting that it's that
high in number here's the real question
then what happened to Joker's brain he
was tortured as a kid right he was
abused by penny flex ex-boyfriend who
tied him to a radiator and his brain was
pressed against the heat of a radiator I
don't know if that would be enough to
dam do you think that'd be like a flesh
wound as opposed to like brain damage
but like if he's doing that to him he
might also be like oh so radiators
radioactive probably right how they work
great really if you live in Canada you
might need a radioactive radio so cold
up there
I'm a snowman in Canadian not a kadai do
this kind of southern if you're from
Canada send your complaints to our
mailbag which we have now we have a
mailbag and we're gonna take questions
that way two questions are you guys have
mailed yeah let's let's crack it open
and by the way you can mail it's your
mailbag questions any personal questions
you have for us well we'll try to get
them on the future episode it's in a
sewer mail at p o-- box seven-11 Burbank
California 9 1 503 somebody's wallet Oh
take it oh and I like somebody chopped
up the mail this this stuff that's great
at Polly doll wants to know have you
guys ever prank someone ever have you
ever been pranked yes we used to pull so
many pranks a lot of place got a job
pulling pranks at one point oh the rock
stars it's a celebrity boxers is we did
do a prank it's a prank on our intern
Devin OS now one of our editors yeah
that's a fun one we wanted to see just
how okay people are with real life in
sense completely inappropriate I had
been pranked by you in college there was
a lot of pranks that we would pull on
each other I didn't hang out with you
guys I wouldn't give you an answer why
wouldn't meet up with you guys wherever
you were it's because I wanted to stay
on campus and get the five dollar five
star pizza campus special and I wanted
to eat it all by myself
and you guys knew me well enough that
you knew that's what I was doing
so you intercepted the pizza I had
already paid for it I believe and then
you took it away and I waited for like
20 minutes and I called five star and I
said where's my pizza and they're like
you already got it yeah we had one of us
but I'll pretend to be you yes and resse
just like you and I went back to the
house that we were all staying at the
time and you guys you ate the entire
pizza this is not a flattering there's a
very good I'll see you there were others
yeah I was but then I think you pooped
on a pizza different very different
story they think we're kidding
um one of our friends is really really
really gullible
shout out to Skylar Kern and we have
just watched Cloverfield yes and I was
like man and I can't believe that was
based on
true story yeah and he was like what and
then I was like oh I'll tell you more
later and then we like schemed how do we
get him to really believe this and so we
very quickly created a whole Wikipedia
page about the true story of Cloverfield
when he came in we like casually brought
it up again he asked like guys you're
kidding right this never happened were
like we're telling you Skyler the
Olympics that were in Mexico City yeah
they were interrupted by El Culebra the
theater for the dirt snake which came up
from beneath the earth like a hundred
thousand based on folklore yeah exactly
we just came with all these weird
details that sold it so firmly for him
didn't we change the Wikipedia page of
Mexico City City and we created like
rebuilt after the destruction from the
dirt snake and had that link to our fake
articles yeah and then we never told him
yeah we forgot that we pranked them
years later he was telling the story to
someone else and they were like that's
[ __ ] and he's like I can't find the
article and he was hitting us up hey I
can't find that article about that thing
that happened in Mexico City and that's
when he finally came clean then we never
talked to Skyler again yeah yeah it was
he's not okay it kind of rattled yeah
okay at yellow mellow ass have you ever
had a superhero moment or been the
recipient of a superhero moment yeah I I
don't like to consider this a superhero
moment but in my first couple years in
LA I was on my way to see a movie at the
Vista theatre that goes like star trek
into darkness or something like that and
it was late it was just about to get
there so I was parking on one of the
side streets in Hollywood and where I
could normally find parking couldn't
find parking but there was a car pulled
over to the side and there was a girl
fighting with her boyfriend and she was
screaming and they were there was like
physical miss going on and I was like I
have to intervene I have to step in I
could get stabbed but she was crying and
I pull out of my car and I run over and
I go hey boy the crazy voice and she
cried and he goes [ __ ] off and he gets
in the car and peels out and I go dude
that dude just steal your car and she
goes no it's my boyfriend
we were fighting I broke up with him on
as he was driving and he pulled over and
you supposed to be driving me home can
you drive me to the train station I'm
like
and I'm like sure fine yeah I'll see a
later show I Drive her to like I think
it's a Hollywood and Highland stop and
the whole time I started because my I
have an overactive imagination like what
if this whole thing is a scam to rob me
Oh hold on did you give her any money no
I didn't give her any money did she seem
annoyed that you didn't know she didn't
I I offered to give her money for like
up train ticket because she was gonna
take my train down to Union Station and
she goes no I'm fine she had a card that
she's gonna use so it was not a scam at
all I here's here's the thing and you
don't know this about this story my gosh
verbatim everything you just described
happened to me like two and a half
months ago or three months ago
and it was like his same thing and the
guy like I was like what are you doing
and he got in the car and peeled out I
broke up with him he won't take me home
now can you take me to the bus station
is what she said and I keep her money
how much money did you give her I don't
want to say how much cash to where you
carrying in that moment you should never
I was on my way to a haircut and they
only take cash and Laurie you getting
your hair maybe she felt bad for me
she's like this sucker I don't want to
ruin his life but also really I only
have this much and is mostly but as I
was driving down Sunset Boulevard I
remembered I have a big knife in my
dashboard thing in the container and I
realized if I have to how fast would I
have to Jason borne my way into that
container grab the knife flick it open
and just stab stab stab stab if I had
what do you mean Jason Bourne open a
container open oh I guess something in
Sherlock in the Robert engine is
Sherlock he's like you go for the for
the rib cage smash the rib cage this is
my real superhero moment is me imagining
what I'd have to do defend myself if I
had you know that she was getting those
vibes wow you would kill someone
immediately that is the most intense
thing that's ever happened to me
Wow I've had a very simple life I
already told my story on rogue theory
recently where I made that movie stop
with my mind because I didn't want it to
go on anymore in the head of celluloid
melted last question for this week
woo hoo oh it's a deep one at don't be a
Rick asks what is your dream bathroom
setup okay so as I've said on an episode
of explain I would live in the shittiest
slum if it had a nice bathroom I need a
good bathroom I'm tired of these small
toilets that every department and LA has
like are we all tiny people how do you
parts of you were touching the side of
the toilet if it's not more than 18
inches wide explain to people what is
different about la toilets we're from
Florida where those toilets are yeah
they have cushions oh it's perfect like
there every bathroom in Florida is
designed for you to spend hours in there
in LA there's there every bathrooms tiny
most of them are half bathrooms they're
low to the ground do you also have the
thing where you kind of like have to
trust that the toilets still there as
you drop on do right yeah it's up what
your distance all and you don't have
muscle control in your legs at that
point so I just want a big industrial
toilet that sucks everything to hell and
I never have to see it again
I don't it's low water pressure toilets
it gives me anxiety
I want to his-and-her sinks I want birds
that sing to you while you're showering
I want a shower that you can sit down
and came to Carson yeah I think I'm just
gonna tweak a little bit here my
adjustments for an ideal bathroom setup
kiss her right if you are in a
relationship when you live with someone
separate bathrooms oh yeah is your
biggest game-changer I know it sounds
like obvious like whatever but it is a
game changer to just have your own
bathroom to just purge all your sins too
and they have theirs to do the same yeah
that's one too high water pressure in
the shower
oh look which people are gonna give me
[ __ ] for saying this but to undo that if
you don't like your water pressure take
off the the head of the faucet in there
you'll find an item that's actually
reducing the flow it's a flow restrictor
what you can just pull that thing out
and then put it back on and then you get
full form for Spyros it's like taking
the muffler off your your car it kind of
yeah if you're an [ __ ] I did all my
showers and they like beat me and it
feels great like a fire hose yeah that
and I need a good tub I don't have any
tubs in my current house and it I'll
never relax again yeah yeah and then I
want a separate room for the toilet
that's like in the four corners that's
the thing I think remote or that's the
episode of Rick and Morty
just came out like you want your
whatever your bathroom is it needs to be
far away from everything and only you
know about it we had that in college the
hidden bathrooms yes so we didn't tell
anyone they're like what are you going
right now like don't talk to me guys you
know way too much about us no but that's
the whole point of this show yes that's
been this week's episode a big question
a reminder to hit us up with questions
for next week using the hashtag big
question you can get featured on the
show
when these silly Twitter handles will be
yours next and and and let us know what
you like about this show if you want to
see different kinds of questions
answered where we just love making this
an interactive Q&A thing where we can
finally have an opportunity to answer
the things you guys have always been
asking it so we kept in two other videos
I've been Eric Voss I'm slightly drunk
make sure to follow us at UA vas at
Philip Malina on on everything and see
you next week
[Music]